hey what's up my name is Samuel Leeds
and I'm a property entrepreneur and only
do I make a lot of money in property but
I also put out YouTube videos and have a
training company and teach people in
property as well so if you watch winners
Wednesday you'll see a lot of my success
students start off making their money in
a strategy called rent to rent and the
thing is event to rent is you can make
quite a lot of money doing it but like
any business and be under no illusion
rent to rent is a property business and
our business is when you have a product
and a product and you have a customer
and we've rent to rents your product is
your house and your service to the
landlords that's your product and
service and then your customer is your
tenants and in one way the landlord is
your customer so it's a complete
business and with a business you need to
crunch your numbers you need a business
plan and you need to do it properly so
the purpose of this video is to give you
guys some things to think about in terms
of how to be able to analyze the deal to
work out if it's a good deal or not
because just because it's a rent to rent
deal there might be no money down rent
to rent deal but if it's not going to
making any profit then that's not good
or if you're gonna be putting loads of
money into it will mind it'd be worth
just buying a house so how do you
analyze whether a rent to rent deal is
good or bad and how do you look at the
deal and and and the fact is you need to
put in so that's the purpose for this
video now I'm gonna say it's a
disclaimer okay if you want to be a
serious business owner and grow your
property portfolio fast I really think
you need to actually get properly
trained and people say are some who you
only say that because you have a
training company no I have a training
company because I think unique because
it's important and I got trained I went
on training programs and different
things so you know we've either run
programs and there's gonna be a link
below for the probably the best place to
start is the property investors crash
course I'll put a link below it's free
we do have advanced training as well but
I really think it's important but for
those people that maybe have got a deal
if you've got a deal now or you're about
to get there and you like I said oh good
I still nah I think this video is gonna
be really helpful so I'm trying them as
much value as I can in this video but I
would advise getting trained I really
would so renter when do rent to rent is
when you take control of a property you
pay a guaranteed rent to the landlord
and then you then rent the property at
yourself you're on a management contract
or corporate lap and then you rent it
out yourself let's say you're paying the
landlord a thousand pound a month but
you're renting out for two thousand
pound a month
boom shacka you keep any profit that's
what I went to rent deal is now here's
how you have to analyze a rent to rent
deal so the first thing is you need to
be able to work out the return on
investment to return on investment of a
rent to rent deal now I would never do a
rent to rent deal unless I was making a
100 percent return on investment on that
deal now when I'm investing in property
because I'm not just taking control of
the property also own it and I'm
benefiting from the rent the cash flow
and the capital appreciation if I'm
getting 20 percent I'm really happy if I
mean if I'm taking control of something
I want 100 percent return on investment
what does that mean that means what how
much money are you putting down to get
the rent terment deal how much are you
putting down in terms of rent upfront
deposit to the landlord furnishings
contracts any fees associated with
getting that set up let's say that the
it's a 5,000 pound startup fee for the
rent to rent and you say but then you're
making 100 pound a month that's no good
because 100 pound a month is 1200 pound
a year so your profit is 1200 pound but
you put down five grand which means that
it's gonna take you years like four
years or more to get your money back no
good you need to make your money back in
full in the first year and that's like
worst case so if you're going to put
down five grand just to get your rent
around in furnishings everything you
need to make at least 5,000 pound profit
in your first year to make the deal even
worth looking at now I'm not talking
about 5,000 pounds potential profit I'm
talking five thousand an actual profit
in your pocket okay so how do you work
that so that because that would be you
put on five grand you make five grand
back after
the first year that means suddenly
you've got a 100% return on investment
after year 1 you've broken their after
year 2 year 3 year 4 year 5 is all your
thousand your 5,000 pound profit so
that's profit now after the year 1 that
was what I mean by a 100 percent return
on investment and money back after 1
year worst case did you get it back up
to 6 months
brilliant that's the first thing to look
at next what's your monthly profit what
it how do you work out the return on
investment so you need to look at if
you'll get paying the landlord a
thousand pound a month and you're
charged in two thousand pound a month
that to your tenants you might say oh
I've got a thousand pound a month profit
NoHo you've got a thousand pound a month
but you've still got expenses so what
are the expenses with rent to rents
there's actually quite a lot of expenses
you got to pay the landlord that's an
expense you've also got to pay if it's a
HMO or if it's serviced accommodation
which usually probably well because
you've got to force the ring up you've
got to pay for the bells council tax gas
and electric you've got to pay for the
Wi-Fi so you've got all of the bills you
need to know how much those are going to
be now depending on the house if it's
just an apartment an airbnb apartment it
might only be 250 pounds a month maybe
if it's a 5 bedroom out it might be 500
pounds a month but you need to at least
have a ballpark figure and always err on
the conservative side when doing your
figures this is not the time to be a
rose-tinted glasses best case scenario a
person you need to look at the worst
case don't be ridiculously pessimistic
but be fair and look at the worst case
and if you still making money worst case
and you're getting 100% return
investment then you're okay so what are
the what are the running costs going to
be on the property next management fees
now management fees can actually be
quite a lot because here's where you get
traps the management company says we
charge 10% and you're like great 10% but
what they don't what you don't take into
account is if it's a HMO a 5 or 6 bed
height demo they're not only going to
charge you 10% of the rent but every
time a new tenant moves in or moves out
they'll charge you a fee usually a
tenant fine fee now if you're in the
wrong area you've got tenants coming and
going all the time every three six
months of tenant moves out and you're
having to pay the agent a new finder's
fee
you've got a factor that in so you need
to look at how long are the tenants
likely to stay what are they
management costs going to be and the 10
find costs so that's the next big fee so
you've got the landlord costs
you've got the management fees you've
got the bells you've also got
maintenance maintenance now I usually
say 10% of the total rent so if you're
getting two thousand pound two hundred
pound on maintenance and then finally
the other big cost and there might be
little of the cost as well maybe
insurance it depends on who pays that
what deal you have but next is that
voids that can be the killer because if
you're if you're expecting to make 500
Panama's profit on a 6 bed HMO and you
rent in each room out for 500 pounds
that means that actually the first five
rooms are just go in towards costs the
first couple of rooms might be a
thousand man to the landlord then few
rooms but we could and actually your
your profit is that last room if that
last room isn't rented out what's your
profit nothing
so just to break-even you've got to have
five of the six room so that's how you
need to think so will this make profit
even if one room is empty all of the
time you've got to look at that how
likely is it that this property is going
to be full all of the time if it's
serviced accommodation and you're
working on a 100% occupation right it
might be the John down the road her
serviced accommodation apartment and he
had 100% occupancy rate but is that
realistic you've got to be really really
realistic now this video might sound
negative but leave me I'm not being
negative I'm being realistic and I and
many of my students make a lot of money
but you can unique if the deal doesn't
stack don't try and force it to stack
find a deal that's more profitable where
even when you're working on the worst
case figures you're still making good
profit so maintenance voids management
utility bills and running costs these
are the things you need to look at and
then and then the fifth one is then
payment to the landlord if after all
those costs you're left with a hundred
pound a month that's not really that
good that's not really that good a lot
of people with rent two rents what they
do is they manage it themselves which
does
making it much more profitable but then
it's not completely passive but you just
you've got it you've just got a factor
with how you want to do it do you want
to manage it or do you want to sit or do
you want to set up systems where you
don't manage you at all so once you've
worked out all the expenses and then
looks at what the total wentz going to
be not the expenses off of the rent and
you see the profit that's left
take the monthly profit times it by
twelve and that will give you a figure
which will be your annual profit then
look at your expenses that you're going
to put down to get the rents around and
if you're not going to make your money
back within the first year don't do the
deal that's my advice that's how you
analyze rent to rent deals I hope it's
been helpful if you have found this
video helpful and if you'd like to see
more videos like this please do smash
the like button also subscribe to the
channel and turn the notification bell
on if you'd like to see videos about how
you can make money with Lease Option
agreements it's a strategy that I love
it's very similar to rent to rents but
you get paid capital appreciation as
well so if you want to see that video
you can check it out right here if you
want to see stories of my students that
have made a lot of money using rent to
rents then you can watch this
inspirational video right here and of
course don't forget to book onto the
property investors crash course where
you can be trained and you can become
successful too and you get your free
tickets right down here look forward to
seeing you there and thanks for watching
the video peace